and if you ignore everything else this
is the one where you stop and you pay
attention because this could save years
of your life it is so easy to get lost
in the day-to-day grind of what you do
what any of us do letting other people
come in and degrade what you think of
yourself is one of the most dangerous
and damning things that you can do the
motivation watch a top ten with believe
nation
what's up believe nation its Evan my one
word is believe and this channel is
designed to be a part of your daily
success routine so let's get your
motivation to attend and get you
believing in you grab a snack and chew
in today's lessons from a man who went
from growing up in a morbidly obese
family being dead broke and unable to
pay his bills to building a
billion-dollar company and now
dedicating his life to pulling people
out of the matrix and having one youtube
channel that is among my favorites he's
Tom bill you and here's my take on his
top ten rules of success volume 7 also
if you want to know what Tom and other
successful entrepreneurs have to say
about building unstoppable confidence
check out my 250 for confidence series
where every day for the next 254 days I
will send you a free morning short video
to help build your confidence the link
to join is in the description below
there's a gap between who people are and
what they tell you they want to
accomplish
[Music]
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one don't let obstacles break you as
Confucius said when it's obvious that
the goal cannot be reached don't adjust
the goals adjust the action steps that
may be the single best piece of advice
you're ever going to get write that down
burn it into your flesh tattoo it on
your soul do whatever you need to do to
remember that once you set a goal once
you've decided in your life there is
something that you're going to make come
true don't let anything stop you from
reaching that but the reality is is you
go things are gonna get in your way
there will be an inevitable slew of
obstacles coming at you but when it gets
so hard that you realize that the path
that you're on is simply not going to
take you where you want to go rather
than give up on what it was you said you
were gonna do find a different path and
in that when you really make that the
cornerstone of your identity that you
refuse to bend or be broken by obstacles
by challenges but instead you rise to
those challenges you go over under
through them you do whatever you have to
you devise any plan to find a way
through then your life will change once
that becomes your reaction to not change
that thing that meant so much to you
you've dedicated your life to making it
come true that you don't change that but
rather you find another way you tap into
your creativity you find somebody that
can help you you do whatever it takes to
get on the other side of that you do
whatever it takes to build that life
that you want to see but if your
reaction is to change your goal to make
it easier to move it closer to be less
of who you could
be simply so you can check a box you're
never gonna have anything that's worth
having rule number two
take the first step why like if you had
to boil it down why didn't L got it
locked the answer is they never start
now the reason that most people never
start is because they don't think that
they're gonna get a result from their
actions and then that's gonna come down
to a belief that they believe about
themselves I'm too stupid I'm not good
enough I don't have the natural talent
I wasn't born at the right time or in
the right neighborhood my parents didn't
teach me that that's why most people
fail there's a great quote by Amelia
Earhart I'll paraphrase the hard thing
is taking the first step everything else
is just persistence and I've always
loved that quote because it's so true it
doesn't mean that you're going to get it
right it doesn't mean that just because
you start you're gonna win in fact most
likely the first thing you do you're
gonna fail think about all the times
that you guys tried something and it
failed or the first time when you tried
to get the business going and it didn't
work or the first house you tried to
sell and nobody went for it or the first
time you lost money and the question is
what did you do then if you learned from
it double down figured it out focused
only on the truth then you'll move
forward you move forward because you
believe you can learn and that's that
thing hiding in that and this is the
thing when people ask me hey my mom or
my wife or my husband whatever they
don't have that belief system they don't
have what Carol Dweck calls a growth
mindset how do I get them there the
answer is you don't until they are
convinced that they can learn anything
that they put their mind to that their
energies double down into that area of
gaining skills will actually pay off
with a real-world ability to do
something new they're not going to act
rule number three outwork everyone Kobe
Bryant one of the greatest athletes of
our time
would show up on game day and if he saw
anybody else at the gym as early as him
even though he was always the first on
the court he would end up practicing
longer than that person and I had the
honor of interviewing one of those
people one time and he said I went up in
ask Kobe Kobe we have a game in an hour
like what are you doing out here
practicing so long and Kobe said I
needed you to know that I was willing to
outwork you and in that game they ended
up winning and that lesson stuck with
that guy forever when you're willing to
put in the work when you're willing to
take control of your environment and put
yourself through the stressors required
for adaptation you literally can become
anything and my life is proof of that
rule number four prepare for the luck I
hear people talk about luck a lot and I
know that people think about the role
that luck plays in their life but the
reality is luck is all around luck is
ever-present luck literally is coming to
you every day it's passing you by it's
happening to you right now but the
question is are you able to take
advantage of the luck have you prepared
for the luck and I think that it comes
down to we have a misconception about
what luck is we think of luck as
something as being passive that we sit
we wait we're in some obscure place and
still somehow the luck finds us but the
reality is were awash in luck
what we're missing is the ability to
make use of it if you have a bunch of
bullets but no gun you really have
nothing if you have a gun but no bullets
the same thing that magic moment comes
together when you have two things that
work in conjunction and you have them
both you can't have luck without the
diligence you can't have success without
the skills you've got to spend your life
preparing to capitalize on that look and
to look at what somebody has done to
look at a moment of success in their
life and to say that it was luck is to
create a frame of reference for you in
which you can't see how you yourself can
leverage what you have to get lucky rule
number five find deep fulfillment one
thing I want to make really clear and if
you ignore everything else this is the
one where you stop and you pay attention
because this could save years of your
life the game you're playing is not
success the game you're playing is not
money the game you're playing is brain
chemistry the only thing that matters in
life truly the only thing that matters
in life is what you think about yourself
when you're by yourself and have nothing
but your own thoughts if in that moment
you feel good about who you are who
you're becoming what you're capable of
and what you're willing to do to make a
better future for yourself those you
care about and other people around you
you will love your life it is the single
most pleasurable neurochemical state is
deep fulfillment okay not happiness a
bowl of ice cream brings me a lot of
happiness but it is a very transient
experience deep and lasting fulfillment
matters and what that comes down to is
how you feel about yourself when you're
by yourself rule number six know your
why the piece of advice that I always
give to somebody whether it's an
entrepreneur or somebody who wants to be
the greatest parent of all time
what is your goal you've got to start
with your goal
everything works backwards from that
Simon and I did a video that essentially
broke the internet about Millennials
somebody watched it what got Simon on
the world stage is this whole concept of
why you've got to know why you're doing
what you're doing if you're just showing
up every day to cut and dye hair to keep
your lights on you're gonna have far
less energy to make it through the hard
times than somebody who is there to help
transform somebody to help make somebody
their best to help them feel their best
and I hope that you guys saw that video
not too long ago of the hairdresser that
went around and he was doing makeovers
on homeless people right man it was
incredible it was so beautiful
the look on their face at that moment
where they see themselves for the first
time in front of the mirror and they are
seeing something totally new they're
seeing a version of themselves that they
did not know was there and the ability
to give that gift like it is so easy to
get lost in the day-to-day grind of what
you do what any of us do but if at the
core I view is a deep and unending why
for what you're doing you've got
something now you've got a chance to
transcend what you're doing and the way
that happens is very tactical has
nothing to do with like whoo being down
there it's none of that you're gonna
have the energy that you need to fight
through rule number seven protect your
vision we get to decide who we are
there's no objective truth that you're
going to find or uncover you're simply
the collection of the things that you
believe to be true about yourself and
once you begin to form that opinion of
who you are you'll act in accordance
with that belief you begin to shape a
vision of yourself in your own mind and
that becomes the reality so letting
other people influence that letting
other people come in and degrade what
you think of yourself is one of the most
day
and damning things that you could do
because they cloud your ability to craft
to craft a vision of the person that you
want to become and that vision is so
hard for all of us to hold on to that we
have to protect it we have to keep other
people out of that we've got to have
intention in creating the person that we
want to become rule number eight get
better you are all hopelessly average by
birth we all are and that's the great
news because the most important thing to
understand about the human species we
are the ultimate adaptation machine if
you guys were paying attention not too
long ago they sequenced the human genome
and they realize that the human genome
has 20,000 genes and everybody they
thought that they were going to cure
cancer all the diseases age-related
disease everything type 1 type tight
type 2 diabetes was all gonna be a thing
of the past we're gonna have it figured
out and then we realize that an onion
has more genetic diversity than we do
and how could that be and so they're
literally going is this really possible
do we misunderstand something like how
is it that an onion has more genetic
diversity than we have and somebody
finally said hey maybe all this stuff
that we've been referring to as junk DNA
maybe it actually plays a role and then
they began to realize that all that junk
DNA that was outside of those 20,000
genes we saw expressing themselves is
what is called epigenetics now if you've
ever heard of epigenetics that's amazing
you're way ahead if you haven't heard of
epigenetics let it become one of the
most important things in your life
because epigenetics is what has made us
the most dominant species this planet
has ever seen it is the only thing that
you need to know it's what I call the
only belief that matters the only belief
that matters is that you can learn
anything I don't need you to believe
that you're good now that doesn't matter
who you are now is totally irrelevant
the only thing I want to know who are
you willing to become and what's the
price you're willing to pay to get there
and that's what humans are designed to
do if you put us under stress
we can learn something new we can get
better rule number nine turn negatives
into positives what are some ways that I
can stop giving this negative feedback
to myself okay so first of all you've
got to train yourself to use the
negative thoughts that you have as a
habit loop trigger of something positive
that's the first step to all of this so
I don't think anybody is going to be
able to get rid of the negative voice
and even if you could I actually don't
think you would want to I think the
reality is you want to use that as your
jujitsu flip to get over to the positive
way of thinking to get into that
positive habit loop to remind yourself
that even if you're not good at it yet
you can get good at it that you're going
to learn by whatever you're doing and
rule number ten the last one before a
very special bonus clip is build the
life you want I don't think people
really realize we construct our lives we
build them from nothing we decide what
our goals are we decide in what way to
move we decide who we're going to become
and what we're going to get but it's a
decision it's a process it isn't
something that somebody hands to you and
so if you find that your life is a
misery understand that your life is an
exact reflection of your choices and if
you want a different life you need to
only make a different choice but I know
right now many of you are thinking but I
don't know what way to go I don't know
what choice to make I don't know what it
is that I want to do
and as ROI Maurice Keene said I don't
believe skill was or ever will be the
result of coaches it is a result of a
love affair between the child and the
ball so ask yourself
what's that thing you love and don't
judge yourself if it was something that
you loved as a child that people are
telling you you couldn't possibly make
money and it's that part of the equation
that I want to break for people I want
you to understand
stop asking yourself what you can make a
lot of money yet and start asking
yourself what would you enjoy what is
that life that you don't need to escape
from what is the life that is your love
what is the thing that as a kid you did
whether people wanted you to or not what
is the thing you would sneak out that
night to do because you weren't gonna be
stopped from doing it everybody has
something like that in their life some
spark of interest maybe long-dormant
maybe that they've pushed aside because
they think it's stupid well maybe they
failed once and they think they're bad
at it even though they love it that
sting of the failure has convinced them
to stop pursuing it at the end of the
day
that is what it gives you that energy
the end of the day thing that matters is
what fills you with joy at the end of
the day the only thing that matters it's
not success ensure this hell isn't money
I'm feeling about yourself when you're
buying
the things of giving energy it's what
you think about yourself it's how you
react to the hard things is whether or
not you push blue and when you push
through when you persevere when you go
down the process of taking the time to
structure your life to build it into
something that you want it to be to
build it into something that you're
proud of to become the person that's
capable of the things you want to do
that can first fall in love with
something and do it for the love of it
and not worry about what other people
think if you hate your life I guarantee
you the thing is that you were trapped
by what other people think you don't
want to give it up because somebody will
think you're a failure you don't want to
give it up because it's a paycheck you
don't want to give it up because you're
scared you're scared you don't know what
you'll do next but imagine a world for a
second well all you thought about was
what do you love what do you enjoy in
that moment it doesn't matter if it
changes from day to day just what do you
love what fills you with joy what gives
you that energy at the end of the day
the only thing that we all have is right
now this moment it's what you're
experiencing loving what you do how you
spend your time that's the point of all
of it the point of life is that in each
transient moment that passes by doing
something that fills you with joy
nobody can give you that we've got to
build that life
so go out figure out what it is that you
want to do and brick by brick have the
courage to build that life now I've got
a really special bonus gift from Tom on
how to start asking how you're wrong
that I think you're gonna really enjoy
but before that it's time for the
three-point landing questions time to
move from just watching another video to
actually taking action in your life or
in your business and if you're bold
leave your replies in the comments below
here we go question number one what is
the first step that you need to take
today number two what obstacle will you
not let break you and number three what
are you going to get better at this week
people get stuck they become so dogmatic
they become so convinced that they're
right and that feeling of being right
gives them a sense of self-worth and I'm
telling you right now with compassion
because I want to see you win valuing
yourself for being right is a trap
thinking of yourself as smart is a trap
and I get it man I know how good it
feels when you're right when you have
the right idea and it goes out and it
wins that feels so good but if you can
recognize that over time it can only
paint you into a corner because the
world changes the world is adapting the
very thing that makes humans the
ultimate apex predator is that we adapt
Charles Darwin said it's not the
strongest of the species that survives
nor the most intelligent but rather the
most adaptive to change you've got to be
willing to change you've always got to
be willing to seek out this confirming
evidence you've got a hunger for it
you've got to want to be proven wrong
you've got to literally invite people
into your world that are going to point
out flaws and you're thinking because
your thinking has already taken you as
far as its going to so if you want to
get farther if you want to get to that
next level you've got to stop valuing
yourself for who you are what you think
how smart you are when you're right when
you're wrong all of that is irrelevant
you've got to value yourself entirely on
your willingness to admit that you're
wrong
you've got to value yourself on your
willingness to learn
you've got to value yourself for your
willingness to sit humbly at somebody's
feet and seek their wisdom to not try to
be the hero but instead to try to be the
one that collects the knowledge when you
can flip over into that when you can
value yourself for a willingness to
stare naked leave at your own
inadequacies you'll start to make
progress in life but no matter how far
you've got no matter how much you want
no matter how certain you are no matter
how much the things you've done in your
life have proven to be correct as
Charlie Munger says you must force
yourself to consider arguments on the
other side you can always reject them
you can always look at it and really
think about it and say at the end of the
day it's just not correct but when you
are trying to hold on to your ideas
simply because they're your ideas or
simply because they worked in the past
or simply because you like them you will
fall into a trap of dogma and you'll no
longer be able to see fresh ideas and
move in new directions but if you're
willing to acknowledge that this world
is constantly moving its ever-changing
the only thing true about the future
always and forever is that things change
and if your thinking doesn't change
you'll never be able to keep up so if
you want to do something extraordinary
with your life step number one always
seek out that disconfirming evidence
always look at arguments from the other
side if you're able to do that then
you'll always be able to stay ahead of
the curve and Ageing won't be a problem
because you can stay fresh in your mind
you become invincible when you bend and
not break and that's what this kind of
mindset will allow you to have so if you
want to win stop thinking about how
you're right and start asking how you're
wrong
raise your standard Apple at the core
its core value is that means that people
need passion and not one drop of my
self-worth depends on your acceptance of
me
if you liked this video and want to
learn more about the power of habit
check out the video rent next to me I
think you're gonna enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there we are
what we repeatedly do change doesn't
just happen at this level of behavior
but when you have to change the
environment make a damn schedule